happy birthday Melania Trump what do you
get for the woman who already has one
foot out the door you're Donald Trump an
8 a.m. interview with America's three
headed Walter Cronkite listen well good
morning and I picked a very very special
day because it's milania's birthday do
you want to tell us what you got her
well I better not get into that because
I may get in trouble maybe I didn't get
her so much I got a beautiful card you
know I'm very busy busy running out
listen for presidents okay but I got a
beautiful card Oh Casanova huh you got
Melania the most romantic gift you could
ever give the third love of your life a
beautiful card he didn't sign it but
Michael Cohen did which is just as good
just as good melodia is celebrating by
flying what I've been told is some kind
of Slovenian birthday flag outside her
White House window other cultures are so
strange meanwhile the president talked
to Fox and Friends for a half hour and
Trump was literally unstoppable Chuck
Schumer and the group take you know
years to approve him years we have
judges that are waiting sophist remember
there was no way to break you 70 I heard
that on CBS and NBC and ABC they're all
fake news I heard that for so long I'm
not involved and I'm not involved and
I've been told I'm not involved right
mr. president told I'm not involved
there is no collusion with me and Russia
and everyone knows that everyone we talk
to you all day but it looks like you
have a million things to do yeah
it's exactly what it looks like
don't interrupt Trump it was just about
to explain how Colin Kaepernick is
playing quarterback for the isis jaguars
let him get there but Trump kept truckin
because you know he's got to talk about
his new BFF Kanye West Kanye looks and
he sees black unemployment at the lowest
it's been in the history of our country
okay
and he says you know what Trump is doing
a much better job than the Democrats did
people don't realize you know if you go
back to the Civil War was the
Republicans that really did the thing
Lincoln was the Republicans yeah Lincoln
was a Republican and Republicans did the
thing that's why Lincoln is known as the
great thing doer as he said in his that
place over there address four score and
seven years ago a bunch of stuff about
the thing you know the thing I mean
America has a long history with the
thing in fact some say we're still
dealing with the thing but that's
impossible because Lincoln did the thing
where people say Republicans don't want
to talk about the thing you know what I
saved the best for last
here's Trump talking about finally
kicking that old habit of watching lions
CNN I don't watch them at all i watch it
easy nice I tell you what
I watched leaking lion called me last
night and I did I did I hated to do it I
don't watch things that I can put it out
of my mind it keeps you you keep your
sanity and it works very much I did
watch a liar Laker and his performance
by the way was horrible yeah I mean you
got to keep your Saturday Trump knows
you can't pay attention to the haters
it's like how I never look at my ex-wife
Claudia's Instagram like last night when
I was looking at Claudia's Instagram you
know
she's on a beach vacation with that
douchenozzle pediatrician Antonio I
don't want to see that stuff that's why
I don't look at it so what I checked in
later and saw that glistening boy toy
rub sunscreen all over Claudius
shoulders and catch a swordfish with a
spear abs all the way down to his dick
who likes that I don't know I don't look
at it the point is happy birthday
Melania
whoa enjoy the card yeah I mean they go
all the way down to his dick look this
this has been a huge week for Melania
even bigger than when she learned what
buses are so big watch First Lady
Melania Trump has engineered her own
diplomatic triumphs recently first as a
dignified White House representative at
the Barbara Bush funeral this weekend
and then over the last two days as the
flawless hostess of the French first
family including at tonight's state
dinner yes if anyone knows flawless it's
Laura Ingraham she's a woman with a
spotless reputation just ask either of
her two remaining advertisers Melania
floated through this week with the grace
of an angel see if you can spot her at
this press conference
and yep incredible in fact that's the
last thing you see before you die in a
perfume commercial
[Music]